thank you
agenda items one and two apologies for
absent
we've received apologies from council
lee
newport and councillor christine mason
will deputise for her are there any
other apologies for absence
no
agenda item three number of members
attending there are none
to receive declarations of interest
agenda item four are there any please
yes count of threes
microphone crystal there
okay
for interest in a bungalow opposite this
uh particular development uh which is my
mum's which is being which is basically
come to me since her passing
thank you councillor uh christine mason
yeah i haven't got a pecuniary interest
but i have had contact with residents
and with officers regarding this
site but obviously i'm quite open-minded
but in the interests of clarity
i will say that i've had communications
to be honest i can't remember
what they were about now but
in the past i have now spoken about it
thank you very much
so the item number five is seven
hillside avenue and clear
people present it please
so chairman this application is for the
demolition of an existing dwelling
and the construction of two link
detached four bedroom houses with
associated external works and amenity as
you can see from the location plan the
site is located to the eastern side of
hillside avenue
within the residential area of hawker
the site borders other dwellings to the
north and to the south
along with
other properties within bosworth closed
as well located here
as you can see from the following photo
the existing dwelling is a detached
bungalow on a reasonable sized plot
the proposal is to demolish the existing
dwelling and construct two link detached
two-story dwellings as shown here so you
can see them just at the top there
new vehicular crossovers would be
created onto hillside avenue to serve
the dwellings so they would be located
here for each droning
approximate heights would be 5.1 meters
to the eaves and 8.8 metres to the ridge
materials will be red-faced brickwork at
ground floor with upper walls in white
painting render with grey plain roof
tiles
members will recall that a similar
application was put before development
committee in september last year for two
detached runnings at this site as shown
here
this was refused permission for three
reasons relating to impact on character
lack of mitigation in the form of a
standard contribution towards the essex
coast recreational disturbance avoidance
and mitigation strategy rams and the
lack of visitor parking
the current application seeks to address
the reasons for refusal of the previous
application
so looking back at the one we're
currently considering
so the key material planning
considerations are impact on character
impact on residential amenity garden
sizes impact on highway safety
sustainability issues trees and ecology
so looking at impact on character first
the proposed position of the dwellings
is not objected to in principle however
the plot width distances would be less
than the 9.25 metres per detached
dwelling within the council's
supplementary planning document too
the current application has changed the
dwellings from a detached to a link
detached form however this is not
considered to address the issue around
plot wits which was a reason for refusal
of the previous application as the 9.25
metres minimum frontage criteria is
still considered to apply
the proposed layout and setting would
not have a good relationship with the
surrounding area with the lack of plot
width resulting in a tightly packed
development at odds with the more
spacious character of the locality
the proposal is still considered to be
contrary to policy cpu one of the core
strategy and policies dm1 and dm3 of the
development management plan and the mppf
and this remains an officer reason for
refusal here
looking at impact on residential amenity
the 45 degree test to ensure no
unacceptable overshadowing occurs has
been adhered to
this development would not be considered
to give rise to overlooking or
overshadowing of neighbouring properties
looking at garden sizes both the
properties will be provided with rear
private amenity spaces in excess of the
required hundred meters squared
we're going to impact on highway safety
the site provides two parking bays per
dwelling to the appropriate sizes within
the parking standard document and the
proposal now includes two intakeable
garages to the appropriate sizing which
would ensure that sufficient resident
and visitor parking is provided this
would address the previous reason for
refusal around visitor parking
the two new vehicular accesses are
considered acceptable
looking at sustainability issues all new
dwellings are required to comply with
the technical housing standards
nationally described space standard the
proposed dwellings would exceed the
requirements
a planning condition would be
recommended if planning permission were
to be approved to ensure compliance with
the necessary water efficiency standard
looking at trees there is a tree and
shrubs situated to the eastern and
southern boundaries of the site
the tree and shrubs would either be
removed or pruned the trees are not
protected and whilst they offer some
visual amenity within the site are not
considered to be of any significance and
therefore the works are considered
except acceptable
and finally on ecology the proposal was
in the scope of the essex coast
recreational disturbance avoidance and
mitigation strategy rams as it falls
within the zone of influence for likely
impacts and is a resident of a relevant
residential development type it is
considered that mitigation would in the
form of a financial contribution be
necessary in this case this has been
provided and this addresses the previous
reason for refusal here relating to the
lack of such mitigation i've just one
final thing to mention within the
officer report
upon page 5.14
the core strategy and development
management plan
and reference under the policies and
proposals section
there should be some policies actually
referenced there i'm just going to read
out the ones that we would be proposing
to include within that section and under
the core strategy it'll be policies cp1
which is a design policy and t8 which is
a parking related one and then under the
dm um policies we would normally list um
dm1 and dm3 which are around about
around design dm4 is about floor space
dm 25 relates to trees and dm 30 relates
to parking it's just something we want
to make sure and is on any decision
notice that we send out so i just wanted
to reference that as an addition to what
you've currently
seen
this application chairman is
recommending for a refusal for the
reason outlined in the report
thank you very much claire
we have no
um
no one to speak on this no visiting
members so i'm going to give it pass
this over to council christine mason as
the world member you will have five
minutes to speak christine thank you
[Music]
is it on
yeah uh thank you
chairman
i must admit i concur mostly i think
with the officer's report but i would
like to look at the first slide first
the one of the existing property
and and to look at the curb there
because i know there is a parking issue
in that area
it's often um
yes i thought so there's one sort of
access there
which would
no longer be there'd be two
so the whole thing would be then curved
with it
dropped curbed
could you just clarify the difference
between
the curb curbage there and the curb is
proposed please
so um it wouldn't be full length of
curving
let me zoom right in but it would be
two sections obviously a lot wider
curving than we've currently got and
somebody zoom in quite a bit more so we
can see a bit more closely
so
as you can see here that's the proposed
curving that they're looking at there
and
and there as well so there would be a
section in the center but there will be
these two much wider um drop curved
elements
um essex county council highways have
recommended a condition which says that
they shouldn't be any greater than 4.5
metres in width
thank you
regardless of that there will be the
loss of off-road parking in an area that
has from my experience when i've been
walked around that way which it goes
relatively
frequently
has difficulty with parking anyway
there's quite a lot of parking there
because well i don't know why to be
honest because most of the houses have
got access and have got car parks i
don't know if it's coming from outside i
don't think it's coming from the school
i think it's a little bit too far
from that even the turning bay at the
end of the road is sometimes
congested
so
whilst i
see that the
loss of visitor parking has been
addressed i think there will be an
impact
on the parking in the area but my main
concern
is
the
plot with and the
relationship of the properties to the
adjacent properties
these properties if you put them
somewhere else would be highly
acceptable
in that location they're out of keeping
the visual immunity is quite different
the properties around there tend to be
varied and spacious
these
don't actually acquire with either of
those
um
with this ceremony so i would be
inclined to endorse the officer's report
for refusal and if the unless anyone
wants to speak further i'm quite happy
to move that
counselor foster are you do you want to
speak or do you want to second the
motion
yep
yep
one point have we got any pictures of
the uh street scene around it yes i
haven't actually shown members i know i
know it christina's an obviously um
council does
who don't know this will see be able to
see the streets see as it is yes just
i'll use my
so that's the bungalow up here and then
so this is looking
south
down um
down hillside avenue
sorry i've taken a few of the
surrounding street again
that's obviously the bungalow that we're
considering
again that's obviously looking we're
looking north there so you can see the
adjacent dwellings there
i don't know if i've got too many far
and that's going so that's again looking
south we're going around the bend of um
hillside avenue there you've got some
properties set in the back there and you
can see
some vehicles there
thank you i think is that enough sorry
yeah that's probably further out look at
that one yeah okay thank you claire
councillor foster
um thank you chairman
a couple of points
um
first of all i'd note that the reasons
for rejection last time have been
addressed
um
the reason for rejection tonight
says the proposed development is
considered to be detrimental to the
character and appearance of the site
and the surrounding area contrary to
policies within the development
management and core strategy
on page 5.5
item 3.17
it saves the part of the hillside avenue
consists of an eclectic mix of
architectural styles
in considering the mixed character and
appearance of the surrounding area with
significant variations in height scale
and design there are no requirements in
this location to follow distinctly on
design
so i see that as something of a
contradiction to the conclusion
and the recommendation
and also commenting on council mrs
mason's comment about parking
it would seem perverse if it were
rejected last time for lack of parking
and now it's proposed to be rejected
for the reasons that uh council mr mason
said of having parking but
losing
on street parking
so if i were that not already proposed
for uh
rejection i would have been proposing
remove acceptance
i just want one clarification
we rejected on three items and only two
have been addressed haven't they that's
correct yeah yeah so
so it's uh parking has been
uh addressed
the contribution has been addressed but
it's a street scene that we've got the
issue you have an issue with yes if i
may chairman that's why i pointed out
3.17
it said
in considering the mixed character and
appearance of the surrounding area with
significant variations in height scale
and design there are no requirements in
this location to follow distinctly on
design
would you like to come back please yes
so just to provide a bit clarity um on
what we're saying there so in that
particular paragraph what we're
referring to is the general mix of
housing design within the street so
we've got a bit of a mixture of detached
semi-attached all of differing age and
style what our reason for refusal is
about is about the fact that we're
trying to
put two detached dwellings in a plot
width that doesn't quite match or it's
not not to our policy and guidance
requirements in terms of sizing so we're
concerned that it's going to be out of
character within the street because it's
going to be quite squeezed in in
relation to
a lot of the detached houses along that
street have a lot more wider frontages
so that paragraph is relating to the
style of the dwellings and rather than
what i read i understand that point but
the
recommendation for refusal
talks about street scene in effect it
doesn't talk about the size of the
buildings in comparison to the width of
the plot
it relates to the streets in with
regards to the layout and setting of
those dwellings that's what it's that's
what we're opening to in terms of
reasoning
okay we've had um
councillor would you like to speak
your turn if you'd like to speak
councilman smith
thank you
um i i was quite happy to uh
accept the refusal last time as you've
just said two of those issues have been
addressed and this is one of those
applications
that clearly is going to
happen eventually
but i was also going to refer to 317
where it does clearly describe the the
mix of uh properties on the house and as
councilor mason said
the
the principle of a development like this
in in many other areas around the
district
perfectly acceptable but we're not quite
there yet it's just a little bit too
much on the side
and i i don't think there would be any
mileage in trying to put anything yet
other as a reason for refusal uh
anything else other than what what's
printed so on that basis um i'm happy to
continue the discussion and secondly
uh the the reason for reviews on the
council mason put forward thank you so
we've got now got us
proposal which is
mr basin and
um
thank you just a clarification the
officer said the
building was too big for the plot with
the
alleyways beside being less than
0.95 of a meter
was that correct so that was one of the
reasons for the street scene
because it's just too big for the plot
could you also bring up the picture of
the what shows the garages
and blow it up slightly because it's
quite
a natural plan please yeah
yeah you just play upside down are they
double carriages or
so
i'm just trying to
i'm just trying to see where the second
little parking spaces are
so the parking spaces will be directly
in front so you've got we would have one
space roughly here and one space roughly
there in front of the garage as well
i'll scroll down and show you a bit more
here so this is the actual note it's not
shown sort of clearly because you've not
got a floor plan for this part of it but
the garage is actually here and then
you've got two parking spaces here
oh sorry
so you've got the garage located here
and then the two parking spaces will be
located there and that be replicated for
the plot below and in relation to the
actual spacing the issue is the actual
concern of offices the actual plot width
itself so we have a minimum of 9.25
metres for detached runnings per um
per detached property for the plot width
and what we're looking at here is a
measurement of 9.1 and 8.9 so we're
beneath that measurement for detached
runnings and we are still treating the
link detached as detached when we're
applying our policy guidance for this
application
have you got a supplementary question
yeah just on on those answers i'm
prepared to
not grant this as well thank you right
we have a motion um for refusal uh
could i just come back on the motion if
i may yeah um clarification because i
know i said that i was inclined to put
motion council smith county secondary i
didn't actually formally put it i'm
quite happy to do so but
i just want to clarify the reasons for
refusal as printed there that we have
policies
and our policies are well thought out
well documented and well understood
and once we start deviating from those
properties we're
accepting a lower standard and we're not
just accepting a lower standard from a
visual point of view but from an
accommodation point of view and these
if they were to be built would be
someone's homes and i think homes should
be of the highest possible standard that
this council
can apply and in this particular area
the properties are spacious they're set
out
as far as i'm aware they don't have
garages in front of them either
which is a design that i personally
dislike but the garages to the front
mean that there's difficulty
if i understand the plans right the
extra parking is in front of the garages
which will then mean that it's not very
easy to access
the garage parking which again is a
concern and and so
it's not just
i understand council foster's concern
about the point in 317 but i think it's
well addressed
and i think it's
misunderstood perhaps and the ca and i
would certainly say that the reason for
the refusal that the officer has put is
sound and should be if the application
should be refused thank you thank you
accountant mr mason so are you actually
now putting the motion in for refusal so
yes yes
exciting clarity and um councillor smith
is seconded right we've got a motion on
the table members for uh recommendation
for refusal can i please have a show of
hands for refusal please
right thank you anyone against
one
so we've got 10-4 refusal
one
against refusal so thank you members
this has been a very quick meeting
um thank you for your time oh a bit
have we got anything else on sorry i've
got to just go through before you all
scuttle off
have you got anything for
oh we've got nothing on the weekly list
no right thank you members and i'll
close the meeting at
1953. thank you
thank you